this time
something goes wrong you'll be one of
the bodies inside of next
what the hell are we gonna do
it was so powerful if you were to fall
there you'd be
[Music]
there's dead easy way up the metal wall
it was very much the focus to get up
there no matter what this is the
altitude
he was hurting
[Music]
off the west african coast
the waters are busy with ships of every
kind
at the mercy of the unforgiving atlantic
a sudden storm off the niger river delta
capsizes a tugboat 20 miles from shore
vessels race to the mayday call but the
tug has sunk
there are 12 crew on board
all are presumed dead
within hours of the tragedy divers are
requested
we got the call to
basically mobilize and assist with the
operation
colby runs a commercial diving team
trained to operate on the ocean floor
nico van gerden is his lead diver
they asked us if we can
willing to recover the bodies
sailing to the upside down wreck of
tugboat jascon4 and preparing to dive
takes two full days
the divers are lowered 100 feet in a
diving bell to find and recover 12 crew
members
i've never had any training when it
comes to recovering dead bodies the just
on 4 was the first time i ever
experienced something of that in my life
i think everybody was preparing
themselves really for what we've got to
do
all right just make sure all our guess
is okay okay
guys i'm gonna get the basket down to
the short mark again okay
no need to worry it's clear from your
umbilicals good position
deep water diving makes normal air toxic
to breathe so nico and second diver
daryl breathe a helium oxygen mixture
the helium changes their voices
get a hammer ready please daryl and one
of those wedges is going between the
door
all right
the first job is to find a way inside
the vessel the security situation in
nigeria with piracy and kidnappings they
lock themselves internally they call a
lockdown procedure to stop them being
boarded by pirates
in the control room above colby watches
the murky picture from nico's helmet
camera
the water is thick with silt from the
niger river
get the wedge and knock the hinges
took me about two and a half hours to
break one of those doors down
the first thing i found was the captain
the captain was obviously deceased
when i saw his face i knew he was
actually in another vessel that i worked
on
i didn't know him personally but i knew
the
the i knew his face
you're right
all right well done that's a good job
all right
coming back to the door
colby guides nico back inside to look
for eleven more bodies
always be away with your balaclava
places okay
nico's umbilical delivers his breathing
gas
his life depends on it
you just lodge the cupboard or fridge or
something and it falls on your umbilical
it might you might get trapped inside
there and then that could be a very very
dangerous situation
oh that's a good thing
[Applause]
they're still sleeping
to search the crew's cabins nico must go
to the next deck
deeper into the confusing upside down
wreck
all right looks like we're going to go
down the stairs
okay
just be a little bit more vigilant right
i'm thinking ish that's a worry for me
because it's umbilical you don't know
what kind of hazards the visibility's
poor took us a little further than what
we normally do but out of our comfort
zone
yeah
let's get down to the next level where
we go next
go around the corner the railings will
be above you
just talk to me and i'll help you
you've gone into this vessel and
everything's upside down
you know i'm just going around so many
corners and bends i was very nervous
i don't want to get stuck how's your
umbilical it's not going to get trapped
in any of those corners just be aware
you couldn't see anything so
if you feel where you are
you're right there
no problem get yourself orientated
in the back of your head you've got that
thing if something goes wrong you'll be
one of the bodies inside it they'll come
look for you next
have you come into the next deck
[Music]
you should be walking on the ceiling
yeah
okay
just
just keep him there keep him calm okay
this man has survived in a pocket of
trapped air 100 feet deep on the ocean
floor for three days
all right just um just reassure him on
the shoulder
man
i think i was a bit in shock i was
frozen there for a minute or two
just tell him to relax we are going to
help him
keep reassuring him all the time
give him a thumbs up okay
ask him if there's anybody out
open your hands like this
nothing
he
says for a long time but now it's been
quiet for a long time okay
i wasn't expecting
anyone to be alive
there's no protocol for any of this just
change the whole scenario
all right what are we going to do
is he's struggling to breathe
you should make a call to one of the
topic
breathing the same air for three days
vital oxygen has been exchanged for
carbon dioxide
this man is being suffocated by the same
air pocket that's kept him alive
i don't want to rush in blindly with
anything we've got to have a
just gotta
keep him alive
he was really really struggling and
i to be honest another hour two hours he
would have been
yeah we've got to try and find a way how
we're going to get it to the surface
what are we going to do
nico colby and the team have no
experience or training for a deep sea
rescue
co2 is bad that we need to get an
airline again
some clean air if you know what i mean
that could be a problem
you just need to really brainstorm this
out because he's suffering from co2
i don't know what we're going to do
he's alive he's alive
okay
i wasn't expecting anyone to be alive
a survivor has been found after three
days trapped in a shipwreck
100 feet below the surface
the dive team came to recover dead
bodies but now they need to get this man
out alive
what does the doctor say what are we
gonna do
yes deception
behind the scenes a team of doctors
approve a plan
but it's risky
yeah roger all right what are we gonna
probably do guys you're listening
so we're going to be taking a stand by
uh a harness
okay as well as the band master the
umbilical okay
and we're going to take it into the
wreck and go and get him okay and he's
gonna come into sat okay
all right we'll slowly walk him out
darrell you're gonna have to tender both
umbilicals bringing him back to the bell
okay
the bell is equipped with a third helmet
and umbilical for the bellman to use in
an emergency
colby's plan is to bring the equipment
into the wreck and use it to rescue the
survivor
if something goes wrong there is no plan
b
taking the bowman's equipment we making
ourselves more vulnerable
me and daryl because if something
happens to us
then the bellman can't come rescue us
right nico we're bringing you the
bellman's harness yeah
i'm just there alone i know i'm close to
that
i have been there for days so
i don't know what will happen
we don't want to speak too much away
from him yeah
let's get back in there
[Music]
i came back with water
and i was like i'm not thinking of what
i'm thinking enough to leave this place
not water
let's get that hat on his head so we can
reduce the co2 please
how's that passage to bring him out is
it okay
the helmet supplies him with much-needed
oxygen and now
he can finally talk to the crew
what's your name
harrison
okay harrison my name is colby
okay and i'm gonna bring you home okay
and the diver that's helping you now his
name is nico
okay that's nico okay
what is your rank
i felt so bad that i've lost all the
guys that was there with me
i know within me that the only way i can
get out of the boat i must go through
the water
so now you must just stay calm and you
must listen to me okay and i'll tell you
what to do
and we're gonna take you to the bell
okay don't worry we're gonna bring you
home okay
safe and sound
it was quite stressful for me because i
didn't know exactly i was gonna react
you don't know if you can swim
if he was halfway through the water and
he started panicking that would have
been a uncontrolled situation completely
to me that was quite stressful
okay how's that
are you all right harrison
are you comfortable
okay all right let's go let's take him
nice and slowly okay hold your umbilical
harrison let go okay we're bringing you
home
all right harrison what are you doing
we're taking you up the stairs
and you're coming up onto the forecastle
okay
all right just breathe nicely eric
you're doing well doing a very good job
my friend and he told me you're going to
struggle just hold the umbilical so you
can go with me so i was just like
following him
hold your umbilical nice and tight
bringing you home nicely okay
are you feeling harrison
okay you must just respond to me and say
yes i'm doing well okay
yeah you must say roger okay
all right
taking him from the vessel into the
valley safe is about 10 meters through
the water and there's a line called the
green rope that's attached to the bell
in the open water if harrison panics and
swims for the surface
the pressure change will kill him
the only way up is in the bell
harrison has to reach it
okay can you see the green rope show him
the green river
look for the green rope harrison
harrison hold the green rope
um open his onboard gas open all the
onboard gases
to development
harrison
harrison
the clock is ticking as second diver
daryl hauls harrison to the bell by his
umbilical
all right stick his head in what is it
once inside harrison regains
consciousness
how are you feeling harrison
all right very good you scared me there
all right you must say roger when i'm
talking to you
are you the bell harrison
good job my friend well done
you're a survivor
all right guys let's come home okay
harrison back in the back
went with three came back with four
it was like someone had lifted all the
bricks off me
huge relief
you've all done a good job thank you
i felt like i was on top of the wall
there saved someone's life
hold on darryl i pulled it back like a
machine
i just saw this body again
all right guys hold on hold on
let's come home okay
i knew
that my life
everybody was just celebrating for me
i was very very happy
all 11 of harrison's shipmates
perished in the tragedy
inspired by the brave men who saved his
life
he trains to become a diver
i want to dive and i want to do it in
the best i can
i want people to know that i'm not
afraid of
my fear
because diving is cute for me
but i believe someday inside of me that
i will also rescue somebody through the
same process
that is why i took the courage to become
a dying
the rocky mountains in western canada
are a rugged paradise for outdoor
enthusiasts
it's the perfect destination for
adventure vlogger chase davidson well
we'll see when we get to the top who
films his hiking trips on mountain
trails all over the country
awesome i love it
for his next trip on a back country
trail he's joined by old friend corey
sugar
hey corey we just made it out to the
lake of the hanging glacier recreation
trail in british columbia this is the
trailhead here
here we go overnight 9k one way
got all our
gear we couldn't have asked for a better
day there's only a few clouds in the sky
it was probably around 85 degrees
fahrenheit and the snow was melting you
could sense that feeling
it was just like the
perfect day
yeah hopefully everything works out see
how the trail
goes are we doing so far we're good
good all right so we came to our first
stream here it's just a small one
this little guy here
glaciers cling to 10 thousand foot peaks
all around chase and quarry's trail
feeding melt water into ice-cold streams
that cut across their path
every trail guide warns of a particular
stream
known as hell roaring creek
we thought maybe this was the river
crossing that everyone was warning us
about
and it was easy
doing this
it's a case of mistaken identity
pal roaring creek
still lies ahead
we were probably about 20 minutes away
from getting to the river when we could
first start hearing it
and it was just so loud
it's like a non-stop thunder
apparently this trail
has a bridge that's only here in the
summertime so we figured if we came in
the summer time
there'd be a bridge
well we're wrong
it was just
exactly what the name implies hell
roaring
it was so powerful
the main bridge was broken but then
there was another one set up
just down to the left
it didn't look very safe
if you were to fall there
you'd be dead
i think like me he was nervous
i was like we don't have to do this if
you want to turn back there's going to
be no hard feelings at all
but then corey said
maybe we should just go for it
apparently this trail i had a break
well
we're wrong
old friends chase davidson and corey
shooker are on a back country hike in
british columbia it looks like the end
of the road
since the bridge at hell roaring creek
has washed away but there's a makeshift
crossing and they've decided to give it
a go
[Music]
over 300 gallons of ice-cold water
thunders beneath the 20-foot crossing
every second
if you fell off that bridge
your life was over
yeah that's all there is to it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
let's go slow
[Music]
i'd be lying if i said i wasn't nervous
[Music]
the water was so powerful it almost gave
you a sense of vertigo
within seconds your feet are numb
chase makes it across
now it's novice hiker corey's turn all
right
cory
ready
one step at a time
come here
oh
[Music]
what
[Music]
you can't stand up
he was just frozen
and he's like i'm stuck
what are you stuck on there's nothing
here
stay calm buddy
okay i gotta take your bag off just run
around that one first yeah
okay
y'all get out of this one now
you can't
all right
the water was so powerful it was pulling
him back down into the rapids
[Music]
buddy
i started unstrapping everything that
the bungee cords were connected to
[Music]
okay
you're on the ropes around the ropes
around you
life was basically flashing before my
eyes
but the water was freezing cold i went
right into shock
i just said to him i want to go back
across right now i want to go home
[Applause]
i thought i had lost my best friend
corey has barely survived the brush with
death in the freezing rapids
as his body goes into shock it's up to
best friend chase to get them both home
alive the sense of relief getting him
out knowing we were both okay it was
unimaginable
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that was so cold
instantly gone right into shock
okay let's go buddy
i kind of like just sit on and i
sat there and cried
you
have all these
emotions running through your head
and i'm freezing cold it's hard for me
to breathe
i had no energy
the shock makes corey hyperventilate
exhaling more than he can inhale
as his brain is starved of oxygen he
becomes confused and irrational
we've just survived this whole crazy
event
we're in the middle of nowhere
and we had to go back across that bridge
that almost just took his life
i'm going back across the line i'm gonna
come back and get yours
i got clothes for you once we get back
over
hey buddy
breathe breathe in now okay
the only way home is back across hal
roaring creek
i was
a lot more nervous
knowing what happened the first time
so
his bag was so heavy from the weight of
the water
that i had to take everything out
i went back and forth with all his gear
six more times
made it as easy on him as i possibly
could
we just had to get through this last
hurdle
corey
can you hear me
hey wait
okay
when you come across
don't rely on this with this rope to
hold you
you got to rely on that one
okay
[Music]
i was scared i was scared for my life
but i just got engaged i don't want to
leave my fiance back home i couldn't
think of anything else
corey tethers himself to chase
leaving only one rope as a handhold
listen to me listen you have to push
that one that way
[Music]
don't stress about it don't think about
what just happened
[Music]
good you're good
nice and easy nice and easy
there you go
get up there bud
[Music]
you never think something like that will
happen to you until it happens
hey
you okay
all right
give me a hug man
it was the first time in our lives that
we said we love each other
and from that moment on we have no
problem saying that to each other
[Music]
just one week later they're back at it
looking for adventure i'm not gonna let
me falling in a waterfall stop me
cross another bridge or
go on another hike
[Music]
i'm not gonna let that stop me
it personifies the challenge of climbing
the summer the matar was our focus no
matter what
acute mountain sickness in and out of
consciousness
he was hurting
hey
sam branson and his cousin noah
devereaux have adventure in their dna
is in the family blood
sandstack has done some serious
adventuring in his life
they share their love for adventure by
organizing the strive challenge
a weeks-long charity event running
cycling and hiking from london
to switzerland
sam's dad billionaire entrepreneur sir
richard branson joins the boys right up
to their final challenge
climbing the iconic matterhorn
london to the summit the matar was our
goal
it was very much the focus to get up
there you know and and give it a go no
matter what
the border between italy and switzerland
the 14 700 foot matterhorn towers over
the landscape
known as the king of the alps it's a
mountain with a deadly reputation having
claimed 500 climbers lives
since 2005 i think 10 people a year have
died on the mountain
which puts it into perspective
[Music]
sam keeps a video diary of the climb
starting in the dead of night
we are
on the mountain
and slowly working our way up
kentucky
the amateur climbers are each led by a
professional guide
sam's guide is kenton cool
the mata hall
arguably the most iconic mountain in the
world
it's got the steep ridges
and it's got quite foreboding faces it
personifies
the challenge of climbing
this is about to be sunrise on the
mountain
uh absolutely stunning colors
huge cliff face
below me
it's very technical getting more and
more technical as we get higher up
so let's make sure we do this so
it's a very dangerous mountain it's
steep it's sustained
and it's exposed really exposed in some
places
people fall off
people do get hit by stone fall
occasionally
so we're taking a quick
break on the mountain
to
cut our crampons on
because it's getting really snowy
it's very unusual for this time of year
to be snowy
which is why people have said the
challenge is going to be tough
starting to get good altitude now
it's really expecting the uh
lungs
as sam and kenton climb higher the snow
adds to the risk of falling
and the increasing altitude
makes it harder to breathe
sam's clearly loving it
so we're starting to hit deeper more
technical sections
as you can see behind me this is just
the most extortionately large drop
um
very exhausted
i would say it was more than
three quarters of the way up
you started to know something
so up high
sights like that definitely don't do
wonders for the nerves
this is the altitude
so
every two steps just like if i get
nauseous
it's absolutely spectacular but you
definitely have to keep your eye on the
mountain because
you look at things like that too much
sam started to
say that he maybe felt a bit dizzy
a little bit emotional
the altitude was starting to become a
real factor
the lack of oxygen
is causing sam's body
to shut down
[Music]
he's gone from just being a little bit
slow
to
be slumping over a bit in the snow
[Music]
he was
starting to suffer from acute mountain
sickness
now altitude doesn't care
basically but
acute mountain scene is it will kill you
sam branson and his cousin noah are
attempting to climb the iconic
matterhorn
but sam is struggling with the lack of
oxygen becoming dizzy and unsteady these
are classic signs of ams
acute matching sickness
sam's sudden deterioration takes
everybody by surprise
that reached the point that sam wasn't
steady on his feet and wasn't
comfortable
in himself
very quickly
fourteen thousand feet up the mountain
sam has reached a critical position
above him is a sheer ice slope to the
summit while below lie thousands of feet
of technical rock faces a rope ties him
and kenton together for safety the one
slip
could cause them both
to fall
sam suffered from acute mounting
sickness and exhaustion
and i've deemed it too dangerous for
myself to take him back down
it became obvious that sam was in no
condition to down climb the matterhorn
it just would have been unsafe for sam
and for kenton frankly to be tied to him
as down climbing with sam is too
dangerous
the only option is a helicopter rescue
and the safest place on the mountain for
an airlift is off the top
it's a clear blue day there's no wind
the summit ridge
that's a clean lift zone
so i'm having to be rescued off the top
because
absolutely sickness and
no energy weak
it's too dangerous to go down
make some emotions
at the moment
come on
look at me we're going to do this
we're going to galvanize
we're safely going to get up there
and then pour a chomp
going higher risks deadly swelling in
sam's brain but the summit is safer than
the melting ice slips they're on
noah and the team aren't safe there
either so go ahead of sam to the summit
the summit of the matahorn whilst quite
exposed is actually flat
so you can rest far easier than you can
on the side of the mountain
sam stops filming and fights his way up
as he does dad richard flies over to
celebrate the team's success
unaware of sam's situation below
it's okay buddy
with just the summit ridge left to climb
kenton calls the rescue chopper
i am a british mountain guide on top of
the metal horde my client is unable to
descend
acute mountain sickness
in and out of consciousness
sam albert collapsed
he starts to like dry he
yeah all right come on we're going to
get up there
we're gonna get you something
so we start
heading up
[Music]
the helicopter on its way they walk the
ridge to the summit
[Applause]
sam defies his dizziness
inches
from the mountain's edge
[Music]
good job stay with me
just stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
trouble
you spend your whole day clinging to a
mountain trying not to fall and the idea
of someone
winching me off the mountain hanging
below a helicopter
was really freaking me out
a rescue technician is winched down to
connect them to a cable
the helicopter comes in a clip clip
sam just grabbed me
and we literally got plucked off the
mountain
it was insane
descending 9000 feet to the valley floor
sam's symptoms clear quickly as soon as
we went
down
i started to feel better
i really do hope that he looks back on
that day and he's proud about how deep
he dug
despite his ordeal
sam still shares his love for adventure
strive challenge is um
one of the things i'm most proud of in
my life
he even brings his dad along to climb
the highest peak in europe a few years
later when you start going out and
pushing yourself and adventuring you
kind of gets in your bones and you can't
really stop
[Music]
you